[Music]
hello and welcome to spectator tv the
week in 60 minutes i am your host this
week katie balls
on the show
electricity bills are going up royal
mail is going on strike airport is at a
standstill and now we're out of water
hosepipe bands affecting tens of
millions of brits are coming into force
why isn't water working i'll speak to
james forsyth and elizabeth brawl
richie suneck and liz trust clash this
week over what support to offer when
energy bills get up again in october
what are sunak and truss's fellow
conservatives making of the contest so
far i'll speak to patrick o'flynn and
isabel oakshot
donald trump's florida residence
mar-a-lago was raided this week by fbi
agents looking for documents he
apparently kept from his time as
president
joe biden meanwhile this week has
struggled to get his jacket on
freddie gray and matt perth will be on
to explain why the u.s is beginning to
resemble the banana republic
and to finish christopher howes writes
in this week's magazine about the joy of
a newspaper's letters pages he'll be on
the show to explain
a spectator subscription is now better
value than ever before
as a new subscriber joining today you'll
pay just one pound a week for unlimited
online and access in your first year to
subscribe go to spectation.org code uk
forward slash tv offer
and why not subscribe to our youtube
channel click the red subscribe button
at the bottom of the video and tap the
bell icon to make sure you never miss an
episode
after an energy crisis train strikes and
chaos at airports we now have water
shortages ross clark writes in the
spectator's cover piece this week about
who is to blame for our water woes to
discuss i'm joined now by james forsyth
spectators political editor and
elizabeth broad expert and resilience
from the american enterprise institute
elizabeth just to kick us off
ross clark highlights the problem the uk
is currently facing when it comes to
water supply how has the infrastructure
got so bad
well i hate to say it but privatization
has a lot to do with it as it says in
the piece
britain's infrastructure used to be
government owned then it was privatized
and today it's owned by a host of
different
owners including by the way the chinese
government now
in itself there's no problem with that
but i think that the problem starts when
when the owners don't uh have the the
long-term uh sustainability of their
infrastructure um
in mind or at least it's not the focus
of their attention and so uh what he
highlights in the piece for example is
enormous leakage which may come as a
surprise as we're all always asked to to
conserve water well while we conserve
water a lot of it leaks simply because
the infrastructure hasn't been uh
adequately or isn't being adequately
maintained so
that's
it is really not something that can be
fixed um
in in any sort of
a rapid turnaround but it's something to
bear in mind because it's we will have
more dry spells we will have more times
when when consumers uh you and i and
everybody else
will be asked to consume water and yet
the the fundamental problem seems to be
somewhere else
and james already we're hearing a talk
of nationalization
uh figures saying that this is a
solution um is it simple that
privatization versus nationalization
when we're looking at the problems that
we're currently grappling with
no i mean there's a better way of doing
this which is that you you keep these
utilities privatized but you require
them to invest every year a certain
amount in the infrastructure i think
what is what is uh indefensible is the
current situation where you had these
companies paying out big dividends to
their shareholders large executive pay
packages and under investing in
infrastructure which is one of the
reasons why we're in a situation where
you're going to have a host pipe ban in
so much of a country in the in the
coming days i also think it's indicative
of something that elizabeth was written
about a lot which is we do not place
sufficient value in this country on
resilience
you've seen that in the decision in 2017
to close the gas storage site at ruff
which is clearly a mistake given the
winter that we're heading for and i
think we need to think as a country
much more about resilience
and how much spare capacity we have for
shocks whether that be droughts or
potential interruptions to the gas
supply this winter
elizabeth what would a resilient water
industry look like
how do you get to the point they're
looking at all the challenges because
yes there is a drought right now
and that is creating this situation but
ultimately uh the water companies are
saying would have to change things
longer term
yeah so
the the challenge i think is so both
when it comes to to crises caused by
mother nature
as as droughts obviously are and the
crisis caused by by hostile states
which is what germany for example is
experiencing with with their energy
supplies that the problem i think well
one big problem is that we as consumers
expect complete
uh convenience at all time we
we want
no disruption in our energy supplies
we've got no disruption in our water
supplies and
if you are a hostile state that's
something that you can exploit that's
exactly what what putin is doing with
germany he's constantly threatening to
reduce gas supplies even more and and
germany
germans worry and fret about how they're
going to deal with that and it's causing
domestic uh discord and and um and
conflict uh and at the same time we know
that we'll have more
crises caused by mother nature as a
result of climate change we'll have more
uh
long ground periods we'll also have more
flooding so all of that means that there
will be disruption and if we as as the
public constantly expect total
convenience then that is is something
that is bound to led to lead to to
conflicts within our societies if we
instead change our mindset and that
starts with with those in charge and
ends with with every single citizen if
we instead change our mindset and say
well there will be disruptions but we
will be uh we will be able to handle it
because we are prepared just like uh
drought areas in in in various parts of
the us know that the drought will come
and they are prepared with i think then
where we are as as james said we need to
aim for resilience and if we change our
expectation
to one where we will
accept uh
disruptions every now and then we were
we are much better equipped to deal with
them when they happen
now james of course this isn't going to
happen overnight but what do you think
are the potential steps uh the uk can
look at now
and so for example there was once talk
of a national water grid that hasn't
come too much you can look at uh you
know some countries in the middle east
with their programs when it comes to
taking seawater and what kind of radical
things should the uk be considering
so i think one thing the uk should
definitely be working towards is a new
set of regulations that require the
water companies to
reinvest a very large percentage of
their profits in upgrading
infrastructure until the infrastructure
is sufficient to meet the the new levels
of demand
uh i think it is also worth looking at a
greater use of desalination for example
so you can take water and use it and
then i think we also have to consider
this in the mix because obviously uh if
we are going to move towards more
nuclear power which is one way to try
and make yourselves uh more energy
independent less dependent on on on on
imports of gas and the like then that is
going to require us having greater
levels of water supplies as well because
water is so important uh as a coolant
there and so i think we nee we need a
kind of coordinated national
infrastructure plan but we also need to
be much clearer with these water
companies which have a guaranteed
customer base that you know and they are
essentially licenses to print money uh
that we expect them to invest the bulk
of their profits in infrastructure to
ensure that there is a reliable water
supply for their customers
and just finally elizabeth right now one
of the reasons i think there is some
unhappiness
amongst the public about the situation
is that it seems the water companies
have failed to invest it's the reasons
both yourself and james have laid out
yet it's being put on the consumer
whether it is you know rat on your
neighbors for using a hose pipe and
floating the ban
or spend an hour less in the shower and
that's how we're going to solve things
do you think there is a way around which
doesn't it you know when it comes to
fixing this in the long term which
doesn't involve us adjusting our own
water use
well as james said that
it would make a complete sense to to put
a set of requirements uh to the
companies wanting to run uh any sort of
infrastructure not just water but but
other forms of infrastructure as well
including rail including uh airports
what have you um and uh and the uk has a
fantastic set of regulators who would be
able to follow up to make sure those
those requirements are being met
but on top of that if we were to have um
companies that then met those
requirements the public would be more
inclined to do its part it
if if we have a situation like we have
now where you and i are being asked to
save every drop of water take shorter
showers while water is leaking out the
pipes because they haven't been
maintained then
the public will lose trust not just in
that company but in the government and
and that
that leads to social corrosion of a very
dangerous kind
but on the other hand if if we the
public know that the companies are being
held to to uh the requirements that they
have signed on to in in taking over the
acquiring
companies or investing in them then i
think every single person would be
at least most of us who would be willing
to do their part
james we're having this discussion
during a tory leadership contest how are
the two campaigns responding to both the
water shortage and more generally the
strain on public resources that we're
seeing at the moment
yeah i think actually it's been a
surprise that this water issue has not
featured in the toy leadership contest
so far
especially when you consider how kind of
controversial the water companies have
have been in british politics
uh but i think obviously in part by this
because the toilet district contest is
being dominated by this question of what
is going to happen to the energy price
cap predictions now are but it will go
up again in october uh in in january it
will breach four thousand pounds and
then it will go up again in april and i
think this move to the quarterly price
cap is quite revealing because when that
was initially uh uh announced or pushed
for the hope was that this would see
bills come down more quickly and i think
it is a reminder of how high hills are
going to stay for so long but there is
this debate now you see i think i think
you can see a difference between the two
candidates and how they would approach
this uh rishi zunak is quite explicit uh
that he would um
he would he would provide further direct
targeted support to to uh the most
vulnerable households he was clear
at the hustings in darlington this week
this wouldn't be to everybody but it
would be particularly to low-income
households and pensioners wallace's
trust is keener to emphasize that she
would reverse the national insurance
rise and take the green levees off bills
and she's reluctant to commit to um to
to direct support though she's not
ruling it out she has been critical of
handouts but she's not ruling it out
uh now the tsunami campaign say well
hang on a second
what you're proposing in terms of
national insurance that has no benefit
for pensioners because they they don't
pay it
and uh the green levees is is not going
to take enough off the bill to act to
help the most vulnerable people now
i suspect whoever becomes prime minister
there will have to be some kind of
direct targeted support package i think
these the rises are just simply so great
it is impossible to imagine uh how you
could politically hope to get through
the autumn and the winter without doing
something like that but i think one of
the big things that has changed is the
fact that that solution needs to be
durable in that you need to be able to
do it again in january and april given
what we know about the further increases
in in the price gap to come uh and i
think this is this is going to be one of
the biggest tests for whoever the new
prime minister is which is you know how
do you deal with this situation
given how high energy prices are going
to stay for how long thank you james
thank you elizabeth
the tory leadership contest could have
been an opportunity for the party to
refresh and have a battle of ideas after
over a decade in power
instead it's been rather vicious in
points and although this trust is far
ahead the blue and blue is worrying
plenty of mps but who is having the
better campaign to discuss i'm joined by
isabel oakshott and patrick o'flynn
thank you for joining spectator tv today
patrick and isabel
now patrick you've been uh very vocal in
your admiration for liz truster's
campaign suggesting that she has
steamrolled rishi sunak um do you think
there's any hope for rishi sunek at this
point or do you believe the polls are
right and it's pretty much a done deal
well i think it's a done deal i should
say by the way that i'm really was a a
kenny badenoch
aficionado before that was fashionable
and i wanted her to win but in a first
choice a forced choice between
uh liz truss and rishi sunak it seemed
to me
that she's much the best uh choice i
think she's run a more mature campaign
and rishi's inexperience has really
told i think it's been a very macho
campaign
from him almost like him and dominic rob
are doing a remake of top gun as
maverick and goose and getting their
cadets to trash talk uh liz uh and it's
gone down very badly with tory
grassroots members uh that i speak to
and it seems to a lot of people that
that kind of rishi was in in love with
the idea of winning and isn't really
collegiate about the future of the party
uh and causing collateral damage in the
later stages of what's now for him a
hopeless campaign
crikey
isabel um you've written uh extensively
about rishi sunik in the past and in one
article recently you said that he was
one of the most intelligent and
hard-working politicians you'll come
across
how do you rate his campaign so far
well um i thought uh patrick's
assessment there was a little bit harsh
to say the least i mean if only it were
a replay of top gun maverick at least
it'd be a bit more glamorous wouldn't it
and i don't think it's really fair to
say that sunac's campaign has been macho
i mean i'm not quite sure what paddy's
basing that on perhaps the early
criticisms that he was mansplaining
and that he was continually interrupting
liz trust i think that the campaign
seems corrected that
i was a big and have been a big actual
admirer of richie sunak i think his uh
he's an extremely able
politician but i think where i would
agree with paddy is in the inexperience
and actually i've been struck by the
sort of naivety of the sunac campaign i
said before all this started privately
to some of those involved in the tsunac
campaign look the only way you're going
to have any hope in this is if you offer
one or two
really significant and totemic
tax cuts right at the beginning of your
campaign that then squares off that
issue
and they simply would not do that
because you know they say rishi
genuinely doesn't believe that's the way
uh to sort of address the economic
difficulties that we're facing the
problem is that once he decided not to
offer any tax cuts and in fact actually
to sort of double down and own that and
say actually i'm standing on a a tax
raising agenda
he had no hope whatsoever in my view you
know he basically
lost the argument before it has even
begun because anyone who has been in any
room with any conservatives over the
last few months know that that is
basically all they're talking about the
need for tax cuts
patrick i was speaking recently to a
supporter of liz trust who's been
working on her campaign and they made
the point that you really need to focus
on the electorate in front of you the
mistake that tory leadership hopefuls
can make is to worry about the one after
that so the general public in an
election and do you think perhaps rishi
cena has fallen into that trap compared
to liz trust in a sense it feels liz
truss's uh plans her policies partly
what isabella is saying are very focused
on their membership whereas rishi cena
seems to be talking to a wider audience
uh well i'm not sure if it's a wider
audience but it is a different audience
and you know it was he's been
characterized hasn't he as the
archetypal uh davos man and he's clearly
one plaudits from leader writers on the
times and the economist and and people
like that it's certainly true the the
the kind of wider electoral polling
shows that tax cuts aren't a great
priority uh for the for the general
public compared to you know four or five
other more uh urgent issues um i think
it shows that perhaps rishi sunak
doesn't know
the conservative membership that well
but i also think it indicates an
enormous sense of complacency uh from
him almost as if you know some very
senior people in the conservative party
backstage have been whispering into his
ear uh about him being the the natural
successor and you know he came to
believe that
and got himself in a lot of wrong
positions not just over not offering tax
cuts but being seen to be uh the prime
instigator of the downfall of boris
johnson which again you know a more
seasoned advisor might have said you
know you don't want to be uh anywhere
near that uh you know you should row in
behind boris now you know he i think it
went wrong for him the day monira mirza
walked out on boris and rishi sunak at a
treasury press conference said about
their kierstama jimmy savile jive
i wouldn't have said it and yet didn't
address the point that kia stammer had
been really brutally rude about boris
johnson in the seconds before boris hit
back so uh from rishi's point of view
you know uh kia was elevated and boris
was relegated and i think since then a
lot of uh core conservatives have had it
in for him basically israel what do you
make of this betrayal narrative there's
uh definitely getting some traction when
it comes to rishi sunak um this idea uh
as as put out by some that you know he
ultimately betrayed boris johnson and
some go as far which i don't think the
evidence for these supports say you know
he is the reason boris johnson is um you
know is no longer prime minister
how does that square up to the
politician who you know you've studied
so actually i think it's a massive comms
failure on the part of rishi sunak's
otherwise very slick operation that
they've allowed that narrative to build
up and i think there are two things
going on here
in the eye of the general electorate
which is as we've been discussing uh the
either mr sunak seems to be focused on
um actually it did him no harm
whatsoever to be seen as a man of
principle uh the one that wouldn't take
any more of this and put his foot down
and said honestly i can't go on because
boris johnson had become a liability and
there were many reasons which we don't
now need to go over for the umpteenth
time why boris johnson had to go
so on that side to the general
population i think uh it's very likely
that his decision looked a pretty good
one you know his resignation letter
looked like a man who has integrity and
wasn't going to just stay in his job for
the sake of it the problem that he's got
in this context is that the tory
membership we now know a significant
minority of them are still boris
supporters and boris fans and we know
this um almost uh sort of numerically
because of the
actual surprising amount of traction uh
that lord crudus's strange and
interesting effort to to get him uh back
on the ballot paper or to change the
rules for the party membership um that
has actually amassed you know something
like 13 000 you'll probably know the
figures better than i do uh supporters
so there was obviously a weakness there
but but but
if he had calmed it right uh if he had
actually presented this properly it
didn't need to build up as such a damage
damaging narrative as it has some
do you agree with that patrick
well i i i'm not sure i agree now in
general that that rishi is kind of more
highly thought of than his trust among
the electorate at large i think the last
few polls certainly i think the last two
perhaps you gov and redfield and wilson
have actually showed that that she does
much better in match-ups against
kierstarma now than he does so
he clearly he began the campaign with a
marginal advantage on that partly
because of uh
just profile but that's ebbed away which
really tells us a bit more about what's
gone wrong with with his campaign and
again liz trust could have could have
responded in kind to all the jibes she
could have raised his fixed penalty
notice his green card his wife's
uh nondom status uh and indeed the boris
betrayal narrative now she hasn't really
done any of that and i think you know
not necessarily that she's some kind of
angelic figure but she's not been put
under any real pressure by him since we
reached the last two in the campaign
that's right i mean in a sense she
hasn't needed to do any of that i mean
once he decided he was standing on a
platform of continuity and let's carry
on with the highest taxes we've had for
70 years she really didn't do anything
at needs to do anything else other than
say i'm not going to go down that route
that's it you know easiest campaign ever
and on that it's about do you think if
if we go with what the bookies currently
point to what will the polling points do
and we uh go along with the assumption
that right now it looks very likely liz
trust will be the next prime minister
part of the reason they wanted to have
this contest over the summer to make
sure that uh you know to go to the
members was to allow for more scrutiny
to really test out the two candidates do
you think we've had that do you think
liz trust has been tested in this
campaign
well i don't think anyone's really
tested until they're in the job and this
is why we build we journalists tend to
build people up and then pull them down
once they actually get to their
destination
i don't think that really if what you're
pointing at is should rishi sunak pull
out um i i don't subscribe to that i
think that there's a process there's
actually fortunately for us all not that
long to go with that process now another
three weeks or whatever it is and i
think
they've all got to stick it out i do
feel sorry for the many young people on
his campaign who by the way aren't being
paid they're doing it for nothing you
know a lot of young people putting in an
incredible hours
and yes it's amazing experience but they
sort of have a feeling of doom about the
whole thing and we've got to carry on
with this charade for the next three
weeks
but i don't think it would be the right
thing to pull the plug on it and there's
no sign that he's thinking of doing that
and patrick is there anything that
worries you about prime minister trust
um from what you've seen so far far we
know that she's your preferred candidate
of the two left um but do you think in
terms of media where do you think her
weak points are
well i i think she might be a little too
wildly thatcherite
for the red wall although polling shows
that red wall voters seem to prefer her
uh somewhat to rishi sunak i don't think
you know
what the red wall was offered which won
them over at the last election by boris
uh was a shrinking they didn't want a
shrinking of the state you know
and uh she is going to primarily use a
kind of tax cutting and therefore stand
on your own two feet uh response to the
cost of living crisis in effect
challenging people to create more wealth
and earn more money uh we're yet to see
what what's targeted support she might
do for older and poorer voters
so that's slightly worries but i think
she's demonstrated a toughness i didn't
uh expect
from her and the key moment i think it's
not now in this walk over against rishi
sunak but in the earlier stages
particularly there was a point where uh
kemi baden not came quite close to
eclipsing her as as the challenger of
the right as the dynamic challenger
and and we had the first tv debate i
think on channel four where liz trust
was very very weak uh very won uh just
didn't rise the occasion at all and she
was in great danger then but two days
later um i think was probably the itv
debate on a sunday evening she bounced
back really quite strongly and i thought
that took some guts and since then you
know she's done just enough every round
and the final two i just think you know
she's faced some fairly hysterical
attacks from the sunac camp but nothing
that's really felt
like it's going to derail her and i
think she's growing in confidence and
her media performances are improving too
albeit from a relatively low base
it's about do you think liz trust will
make a good prime minister
well
let's hope so i mean agree with paddy
that she's got better in terms of
presentation that was always um the
single biggest weakness i thought she
had you know very uh sort of poor
communicator um i remember sitting
through uh one of her conference her
conference set piece uh last at the last
conservative party conference and
thinking that i had never heard a more
poorly presented speech and not only
that the content was absolutely dire
so i do hope that since then things have
changed a lot look anyone can have a bad
day and she's certainly doing really
well in these televised debates now um
so look i really hope that she's going
to be what we need you know otherwise
it's just going to be two terms and the
tories are sorry i'm sorry two years
and the toys are out and patrick you
made a really interesting point just
then about isla's trust to thatcherite
for the red wall and because i think
at this point it would take quite a big
upset i think for people to start
thinking uh you know richard has a
chance of of uh beating her in the polls
so his supporters but of course if they
were here so everything is playful um
but
in the past week i think as it's looked
to an interview you go to the financial
times we're saying no tax cuts no
handouts you saw her supporters try to
roll back a bit from that saying there
could be emergency relief in the face of
soaring energy bills and but then again
uh whenever she is pressed on it is very
clear her instincts are on reducing the
tax burden and not doing what she
believes rishi sunak is doing which is
basically an imitation gordon brown
where you tax people and then and then
you just give them a little bit of that
money back and and then you also have
the windfall tax now there's some talk
today in the papers of how that could be
strengthened and team liz have
completely hit back at that they do not
want to have a winfor tax that brings
them more money or to toughen that up
because i think it's unconservative so
do you think there is a risk that
actually some of these policies which
are poll while such as the windfall tax
which liz trussa um and if her
chancellor's quasi
and are both ideologically opposed to
could lead to a backlash amongst those
redwood voters
yeah that's certainly a risk i mean you
you you know she's always compared to
margaret thatcher isn't she or is
thought to compare herself to margaret
thatcher and you know you could look at
the the early jeffrey howe budget where
he basically steamed in cut top rate tax
cuts lots of other taxes for the better
off and promises this entrepreneurial
revolution well fortunately
they had a four-year term
including the falklands war victory but
a four year term and the economy had
begun to come good now this trust is
already in mid-term of a parliament so
going in with that kind of ideological
quasi-quarten budget which lets big
corporations off a windfall tax would be
a very hard sell unless you know the
economy is seen to come right
in time for the general election so if
she goes down that route i think she
needs to deliver on other things that
red vote war voters care about
particularly
immigration control particularly uh you
know
coming up with solutions to the channel
dinghy crisis i think a much tougher
approach on law and order
too there are other policy areas where
she can win plaudits from but it's a
very risky thing for her economically to
to kind of jump from boris's social
democracy if you like to you know
hardcore thatcherite revival and finally
isabel final question to you um
you obviously researched for this uh
biography of rishi sunek and i think you
said that you found it hard to find much
to dislike
do you think if we look at some of the
campaign errors you were referring to is
richie cena just too nice for politics
you know i thought that at the time that
i was researching um that biography of
rishi sunak
i did think that and it was almost the
only thing that i could find that anyone
would say that was critical about him
that he you know he perhaps lacked the
killer instincts now
you know two years is a long time that
book came out a couple of years ago and
i think we have seen that he does have
the killer instinct
but a killer instinct is not very useful
if you're if your prey is the wrong one
and i think what we have learned is that
yes he has a killer instinct but he's
not actually targeting uh the right the
right prey um what i just want to pick
up finally on what pally was saying
about what a shock it might be if they
go full on thatch right quite quite soon
on when they take over if indeed that's
what's happening
i actually think they are going to do
that um i think that quasi-kuatang is
pretty hard line i think he doesn't mind
whether he's popular or not which is a
novelty uh given the prime minister
we've we've had the outgoing prime
minister really does want to be popular
i don't think that mr quarten if he ends
up being the chancellor cares about that
i think he wants to do what he regards
as the right thing for the country and i
think we're in for a pretty bumpy and
exciting time actually
well with that thank you isabel and
thank you patrick
next let's go across the pond
freddie gray the spectator's deputy
editor writes in this week's magazine
that america is quickly resembling
banana republic with raids on donald
trump's florida home and a president
who's so decrepit he can't cope
is there any way back for america
freddie joins me now along with matt
purple the online editor of the
spectators world edition to discuss
freddie let's begin this discussion with
a focus on joe biden the president
it used to be the case that when people
suggested he was perhaps past it or
senile that this was seen as
an attack coming from trump supporters
but is this now a widespread view
i think so i think you certainly hear it
much more uh from
pro-democratic commentators
uh and i think it's just become hard to
deny the reality
uh that he looks quite decrepid and that
his administration seems to be
struggling on a large number of fronts
however what's been quite interesting in
the last week has been that you've or
last couple of weeks actually has been
that you've had quite a lot of the the
pro-democratic media
in washington dc in particular saying uh
that biden is sort of making a bit of a
comeback that he's back in the game that
he's on a roll and this is to do with uh
unemployment peak employment numbers in
america
um plus he passed this inflation
reduction act
um and he he's made some progress on his
environment environmental
agenda
but to me uh it screams a little bit of
desperation and i have a sneaking
suspicion as i put in a piece in the
spectator this week that it might be an
attempt
among dc insiders to persuade uh joe
biden that he's not a complete disaster
and actually maybe he can move aside
with his reputation somewhat intact in
2024
matt you written a piece for the
spectator uh that effectively uh biden
struggles when it comes to the machinery
of government do you think that's still
the case
yeah i i do
at least right now and it's a very
curious thing because the biggest
selling point for biden back during the
election was that he knew the machinery
of government
uh you know obama might have been a
charismatic force trump too
uh biden may be a little bit less so but
he knew how to get a bunch of senators
into a room and find a consensus right
he knew
uh which elbows to grease he knew which
levers to pull and what we're finding is
he's he's genuinely struggling with that
um
he did pass a massive infrastructure
bill uh that i suppose you can chalk up
as an accomplishment but what's really
remarkable is that the public doesn't
seem to know it exists right it doesn't
didn't really they didn't feel it
tangibly and palpably it didn't really
help them and now he got lucky with joe
manchin coming back to the table uh he
got lucky with this this latest
legislation being signed into law but um
and inflation has cooled off just a
little bit over here but it's
nevertheless still very bad people are
very worried about the economy and and
the democrats even more so than just not
being sure about the machinery of
government they seem to have this
myth that if they can just pass more
spending if they can just dump
more money into the economy then they
can effectively buy people's votes right
they can effectively
bring voters over to their side that
that's really all there is to politics
and the problem is that that hasn't
worked and i don't
i don't think it's going to work now
biden looks a little bit better than he
did say a month ago but uh there's still
not a lot of polish on him at the moment
and freddie how are we seeing failures
in terms of a lack of leadership or grip
and ultimately manifesting themselves
across the united states of course uh
there's lots of countries right now
grappling of high inflation um but for
what what is happening
well i mean if you want to look as
america's sort of part in the world of
course you go back to the afghanistan
withdrawal which though in many ways the
right things to the right thing to do
and a popular thing to do in america was
uh very much botched
uh and then also if you look at what
happened last week with nancy pelosi
going to taiwan that was chalked up by
some people as a win you know china said
you
they absolutely absolutely would not
tolerate uh nancy pelosi's arrival in
taiwan uh even threatened to shoot down
her plane
but she went ahead and did it and uh was
not killed and there isn't
yet uh a war over taiwan however
china stepped up its military exercises
um is obviously menacing taiwan
uh and we see no
further statement from the binding
administration i'm not saying that they
should it just seemed an odd uh slightly
overly symbolic provocation
um that has actually put taiwan in more
danger not less so i think in world
affairs the biden administration is
looking
less competent than than everybody
thought it would be when he took over
from donald trump
matt here in the uk i think there is
just a a growing sense that nothing is
working whether that is the passport
office
what we're looking at in terms of water
shortages is there a similar sense of i
i suppose decline in the united states
right now
yeah i thought you were going to say
nothing is working in the united states
which you'd be totally justified in
thinking that too because we feel
roughly the same way right this is the
problem that america faced in the 1970s
is that it felt like every possible area
of life was coming apart you know crime
was out of control
uh gas lines gas prices were up
inflation was skyrocketing uh
stagflation was on the way as it appears
to be now uh
and it it you know it can be difficult
to look around or to turn on the news
and to see really any
any good news um and certainly that
that's true in foreign affairs as well
getting back to what freddie said before
i i'm not sure that this was a huge
blunder by nancy pelosi i'm not sure
that it's really going to matter in the
end the fact that that uh she visited
taiwan i think there was there's going
to be some noise out of china but
eventually that's going to die down
what i think is that it speaks to
another
uh facet of american decline which is
that we are so used to this imperial
all-powerful presidency and it made joe
biden look incredibly weak
right he
clearly did not support pelosi going to
taiwan he more or less made that clear
and yet she went anyway that that was a
pretty brazen move by a speaker on the
of the house from his own party i it
really um it made him look supine and
so you know again you throw in a weak
president into the rest of that mix and
it's no wonder most americans think
their country is absolutely going in the
wrong direction
now freddie let's talk about donald
trump uh he's been in the news this week
uh and i think i suppose
the leading item relates to the fbi and
that raid can you talk us through uh
what is going on there and what the
potential repercussions are
well i think this is by any measure uh a
staggering story um
it was announced when donald trump
announced uh released a statement saying
that his residence in florida he's in
new jersey i think at the moment
his residence in florida was being
raided
by the fbi
and the briefed out reason from the fbi
pretty quickly became that they were
looking for
documents official presidential
documents that he hadn't returned or
that perhaps he was hiding
there's a lot of speculation that what
they were trying to do is to catch him
on the presidential records act that is
to say that find that he's been in
contravention of the presidential
records act and if found guilty of that
it's possible although some legal
scholars say it's not actually possible
that he could be
banned from running again
and so it looks very much what like what
donald trump says it is which is a uh
pretty shady
uh attempt to stop him running again for
office or just a sort of fishing
expedition
for uh dodgy materials on donald trump
and what i find quite amusing is that a
lot of people
who sort of think this is okay say well
it's like al capone you know uh we don't
we don't get him on the crimes he
actually did but we'll get him on some
minor thing and that will be good enough
i mean whatever you think of donald
trump and i'm not i'm not a big fan
it's not really a good comparison
because uh you know he's not a murdering
gangster
um so i think there's this sort of
element of desperation to just get trump
and we've seen it for six years now this
attempt to get trump
and each time you think surely they
realize it's not working it's
self-defeating because it justifies
trump's narrative that he the deep state
is out to get him they go and prove him
right again so i think it's a very very
odd story uh i think we're going to
learn a lot more about it as the weeks
go on
uh and it could be murky in all sorts of
different ways
because matt this ultimately does have
the potential where to you know go all
the way were trying to be found guilty
of a charge for example not that we are
at the charge point yet it has the
potential to rule him out from uh
running for president again um so so do
you think that we are already hearing
you know conspiracy claims but
do you see what electoral effect do you
think this will have
i think it will only rally and motivate
his base which is going to see this as
an attempt by
the deep state the democrats take your
pick to try to rule him out from running
um the law that uh if freddie is right
that the law that is in place about this
is probably unconstitutional the
constitution lays out the criteria
whether or not you can run for president
you can't really just pass a statute
that overrides that you have to amend
the constitution itself so it's very
likely that this isn't really going to
be a hurdle for him um although it could
go all the way up to the supreme court
the lawsuit that ultimately ensues uh
but but yeah it's going to
i think it's it's going to polarize
everybody even further because on the
other side you have a left that is
absolutely hell bent you know to get him
on something
and leticia james for example the
attorney in new york is going after him
again is going to talk to him this week
it's just you know after robert mueller
after russia after two impeachments
everything that's come down the pike it
nothing seems to be able to stick i mean
you've taken an extraordinarily
uh or what should be an extraordinarily
weak politician you know somebody who
can't seem to stay out of his own way
and you've made him look like teflon
because you just can't
seem to get him on everything he just
wriggles out of your grasp so um yeah so
far as the raid goes i think one of two
things is true here either
trump did take documents like they
really are on to something the fbi knows
something we don't in which case a
former president is committed an
extremely egregious crime and
uh you know could potentially be charged
or
the fbi has been weaponized and is
trying to bring trump down they don't
want him to run again
uh it seems like there's very little
room for a middle ground in between
those two options and neither one
reflects very well on america right both
of them have a whiff of the banana
republic about them and
yeah it's definitely it was on an
encouraging development
and freddie how is the race more
generally to be the republican candidate
going
is it donald trump's to lose
i think absolutely it is i mean there's
obviously a lot of buzz and excitement
about ron desantis
the governor of california
but if you look at the polls trump still
has this enormous weight
of support behind him and it would be
very hard for anyone to stop that and as
the people close to trump are now saying
if there was any doubt in his mind
as to whether he'd run again that went
on monday uh i think they're seeing this
uh raid fbi raid as a sort of perfect
launch pad for his 2024 campaign which
suggests that it's um
if it's an attempt to stop trump it's
it's so far it's been very
self-defeating unless as matt suggests
it's possible that the fbi knows
something very damning
that we don't
and matt when it comes to the democrats
surely there's an increasing sense that
joe biden will not be able to run for
re-election so so is that the case and
who now looks as though the most talked
of candidates potentially in in that
sense
uh
kamala harris um who's even less popular
than he is
uh pete buttige who was a mayor a few
years ago um
i mean it really is this is the
consequence of losing the midterm
elections over and over again right of
ceding 2010 to the republicans 2014 to
the republicans not making as big
inroads in 2018 as you should have you
really don't have very much of a bench
and
you know somebody like alexandria cortez
might excite the left but she's probably
still a little bit too
inexperienced a little bit too young i
don't think she would want to
run for president yet anyway so
yeah you look at the democratic party
and you realize that the republican
divisions and the republican weaknesses
get all the attention
but the democrats have enormous
fractures as well and just a a bench
that
it's not even that it isn't really
strong it's just completely depleted and
freddie you wrote in the spectator for a
cover piece um a few weeks ago about
effectively the problem facing all
leaders in the west
and and i wondered i mean ultimately uh
incumbent governments are going to have
a very difficult time seeking an
election at the best of times you know
even if even if personally they are
respected given all the problems on
energy uh the financial situation so
when it comes to that uh coming election
when we do eventually get there do you
think it is really the republicans to
lose or do you think the democrats still
stand a chance
well i think i mean i'm trying not to be
uh gloomy because everything is so uh
gloomy at the moment but looking at the
you know the countries that you know one
wants to do well in the world uh and
those are uh democracies um with uh
where freedom of conscience and freedom
of speech is allowed um
they're not doing very well and and what
i found uh quite striking about this
week particularly going back to the
trump raid was that
um
as soon as it happened
uh the republicans kevin mccarthy the
minority house speaker said uh that
merrick garland the attorney general
better clear his calendar because as
soon as we get in after the midterms uh
we're coming for him and we will you
know prosecute the department of justice
and so on
and so what you're getting is a
situation where american democracy is
turning into a sort of tug of war
between uh ridiculous palestine factions
who are only interested in prosecuting
each other and meanwhile none of the
very substantial problems that america
is facing are being addressed and i
think this is a big collapse
in american democracy
and on that cheery note
thank you freddie thank you matt
and finally christopher howes who edits
the letter pages of the telegraph and
writes the spectator's portrait of the
week it says in this week's magazine
that the letter pages of a newspaper
give a chance to feel the pulse of the
country to tell us about the joys of the
job and some of the stranger entries
christopher joins me now
christopher thank you very much for
joining us this week in this week's
magazine you talk about editing the
letters page of the telegraph
to begin can you just
offer viewers an example of a day in the
life
well it's shoveling mostly it's like
being a stoker on a a
naval vessel during a war
but
the income coming is it's not gunfire
some readers letters and it's rather
marvelous to read them all
coming in we get about 600 a day minimum
so work it out if you spend a minute on
each one that's 10 hours a day
so i've got a team of people on our desk
who read and read about
and then it's a question of just really
bidding up see which is the best one put
on the page to entertain the other
readers and us
and uh they they go into two categories
really
things on important subjects and things
on unimportant subjects and sometimes
the ones on unimportant subjects are
quite entertaining really i would say
more entertaining than
stuff on the latest crisis in government
yesterday we had a good one from man
in bridlington who'd um he'd been in the
humber
maritime lookout uh if that's the right
title and he was working night shifts
and every day he took in kipper
sandwiches and they were so popular that
he had to bring in a special store to
cheer up his colleagues but then he did
a very interesting thing he said that he
retired 10 years ago
and he's never had a kipper sandwich
since i i think that says something
about the habits of the nation
and when you're having those
conversations about which letters are
going to make the page you say in the
piece for example you tend not to allow
same writer of a letter to go in more
than once a month um do you end up
having impassioned staff debates perhaps
fighting particularly for a letter
oh yes fisticuffs often was bloodshed no
we just really pool our talents and put
things into a hat and then pull out the
most juicy looking
it's a two-way
traffic really because the reader's
letters inform the editor's decision of
what to cover that day
i'm not saying that they decided but
they have a contributory
effect
and at the same time the readers are
following up what each other say
in in the letters page and also what the
news and the comment is in the newspaper
it's marvelous really because
people talk about newspapers having some
kind of community behind them
and i think it's only on the letters
page that actually that comes to life
you talk about people like being limited
to one letter a month well that's
perfectly true but some people write
every day i'm not quite sure why they do
because they must know they're not going
to get a letter in every day but i
suppose it's a good practice isn't it
like practicing the violin or something
my advice would be not not to make it
too long if you want to get a letter in
i would think that two or three
paragraphs is quite enough to be going
on with well you may have beaten me to
my next question and answered it but i
wondered for those
who you know have been writing letters
in perhaps haven't made the cut yet or
are think about doing it for the first
time what do you think your experience
makes for a good letter
well it has to have a human quality it
has to have actually something to say
not just complaint
generally speaking people are on a
little simmer of rage against what's
going on and that's usually what's going
on in the government or what's going on
in the country so just at the moment
it's quite hot weather and they're all
complaining naturally about host pipe
bands
and they're looking forward to winter
when they'll be complaining about us not
having any gas to heat ourselves
so
things come and go in a wave motion so
in the time of great national crisis
like during the mp's expenses uh scandal
we were getting a thousand twelve
hundred eighteen hundred letters a day
day after day
and i really think that they have an
effect on the
politics of the country i'm not saying
it's a good effect because
the mps expenses scandal was a bad thing
but you can hardly blame us or the
readers for wanting to comment on it
i came across a letter a few years ago
which was just three sentences i can
read it out if you want won't take very
long
please it comes from something called
gene mellows in dorking sorry and she
says i was interested to read about the
teddy bear that accompanied
a battle of britain pilot as i too have
a little bear
with my maiden name tape sewn onto it
which i gave to my fiancee to take with
him on his operations over germany
during the second world war
he was a mosquito night fighter pilot
and flew 50 ops accompanied by my bear
and together they won the dfc
we were married for 50 years but now
sadly i just have the bear
and i mean that is really very well put
short doesn't take up much space it made
a real impact on readers and
on poor old social media people were
sending it to each other and then later
on sunday went to interview the woman
who wrote it
and we had a little photograph of the
bear with his dfc
i mean
that is not the sort of lesson you can
write every day but
you only come across those by sifting
through the
great piles of
ore to find the gems
it's like panning for gold
do you think a lettuce page then
effectively keeps the publication in
touch of its readers um in a way that
would otherwise perhaps be harder to do
well it certainly does that yes
and i think that's really why it needs
an editor oddly enough because
you know sometimes people put things
online as comments underneath articles
and after reading that for a bit it's
like a sort of 2 a.m conversation they
start talking to each other about
completely irrelevant things and
sometimes in a bad humor it's like
sitting in some provincial bus station
listening to drunks arguing
whereas if you
present
a nicely edited page either online or in
the newspaper people enjoy reading it
it's one of the most popular things in
the paper and so they sort of
up their anterior and they make a bit of
an effort to write a letter nicely
topped and tailed and i i think that's
what makes for a good conversation
really
now
my first job or my first i think paid
job in journalism was at the telegraph
um and i remember always walking past
the letters desk and you looked very
very busy and as though you had the most
important work to do
and we were polite
always polite christopher nev no one
ever accused you of being anything but
um but i wondered four uh
viewers
are there any memorable i suppose uh
surprising terms the letters page have
have uh you know have taken uh for
example you mentioned a piece uh a
period uh looking at you know british
cars
oh cars well that took me by surprise
because somebody wrote in about their
triumph herald
and
it was at the beginning of the year it
was moderately quiet
but it's just that it seemed to me that
people
remembered
their triumph heralds mostly
for when they went wrong
often because the chassis was a bit sort
of wonky the doors would fly open when
you went round round about a woman wrote
in saying that she lost not only her
hand background around the boat also had
a pet dog and they were both luckily
retrieved intact
and we found that
cars often a british make
and not very reliable ones sort of
punctuated people's lives their love
lives
births marriages and deaths and somebody
wrote in about their car which survived
when their house was destroyed by v2
during the war and it was still going
when he was writing into us you know all
those years later astonishing
and over the years have you seen social
media have an effect on i suppose the
quality of letters going in or perhaps
meaning more people think oh i'll say my
views on twitter about an article and
therefore i don't need to write in um
it has the opposite effect actually
oddly enough get more and more um and um
we don't fear a post strike anymore i
see the post postman going on strike
again but we won't mind because as long
as the electricity is still working they
come bobbing in by email and people
write as as if it was on a piece of
paper and they're usually pretty well
written
and we only get a few dozen now actually
on bits of paper and often they've taken
a long time to come so they're a bit out
of date so there's no more green paint
green ink anymore
because well i suppose you could do
greening can't you on an email but it
doesn't have quite the same effect
and when you're looking at these letters
i wondered what proportion
in a day's i suppose intake are people
complaining that their letter hasn't
gone in
or do people take it well
do you think
so much they can do about it i think
they recognize that it's a it's a fair
game and the great thing is that we do
take notice of the letters even when
they're not published and
often they influence
what what the paper's going to be doing
and sometimes you get what we call
stories in other words
news reports
well up from a letter and published in
the coming days and if the government
doesn't take notice of what our readers
in the daily telegraph
say in their letters which are published
then they're fools and i hope they do
and i think they probably must
it would be very sensible
and because we're speaking it's the end
of an era you are no longer going to be
in charge of the letters page um what
are you going to miss the most or
perhaps
how are you going to distract yourself
from the from the gap in your life after
this well it's not the end of life for
me i'm just moving on to another job at
the telegraph i can do more writing but
i suppose i shall miss
having that finger on the paths of the
readers um i won't think that they're
dead just because i'm not holding their
wrists but um
it's it's something which
you sort of feel part of so i'll
certainly miss that and i'll miss the
entertainment
because
they come up with things you just don't
expect that's a great thing
thank you christopher thank you for
joining us today
that's it for this week
remember if you enjoy what we do here at
the spectator you can subscribe to the
magazine and to our online content
join today and you'll pay just one pound
a week for unlimited online and app
access in your first year to subscribe
to go to spectator dot co dot uk forward
slash tv offer
and don't forget while we have you here
to also subscribe to the spectators
youtube channel
just click the subscribe button at the
bottom of the video and tap the bell
icon so you never miss an episode
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]
you